welcome to this video this is the final
round coverage of this year's Tata Steel
tournament round 11 we've seen a really
great tournament I think with lots of
decisive games and real fighting spirit
have been very little uneventful game so
on doll draws and this last round is no
exception there's not a single short
draw in there so let's get right to the
games first game I'm going to look at
his knowledge against report the two
tail end us meet in the final round
however night it has won is an ultimate
Renault game against Khurana so he
certainly am has some experience yeah
something nice that he before maybe this
has raised his spirits let's see what
happens and I'm glad to note that he's
playing a mainline before opening like
he usually does and not something
strange like in this game against Atari
Krishna report is going for the modern
defense which is in his hands
feels like almost conservative he has
played some real creative and unusual
openings this is quite normal after
Bishop III however he's playing a
slightly weird move Queen to c7 in
general the Queen has quite often placed
on c7 in the and the hoop ilk Piltz on
modern complex but you rarely see it
played so early it's not clear that it
always belongs on c7 but okay this is
probably not a mistake knowledge plate
Queen d2 right to d7 and long castles
very straightforward white is going for
for quick development control of the
center and it's not using any time with
with fancy moves yeah look sure he's now
playing a very committal news report
it's playing b5 which is of course
fairly normal in them in the modern but
here in this position you already have
played Queen c7 for example which seems
like the loss of tempo we sometimes see
this this pawn structure with d6 c6 b5
but without the Queen on c7 and I'm not
really sure that it is well placed on c7
nitrogen next move I believe is really
strong he played me five I'm not sure if
he had yea prepared this or had a look
at this before for some some other game
because he couldn't have guessed that
report is playing the model and he
played all kinds of openings in this
tournament or before that so it's
probably not a specific preparation for
the for the game here yeah why is this
move strong um yeah the the point is
that white is already threatening
something here it threatens to open up
the position with 86 d5 in some cases a
six but the main point is the capture on
them on d6 this would open the center
especially the e-file and black cam is
really not well developed this is often
a problem in the this modern openings
when the position is opened quickly the
the lacan development and the many pawn
moves like b5 b6 and so on they can
backfire them the the first problem is
if black now and captures which you of
course need to need to check after oops
after Knight takes e5 White has a number
of
options it's mostly connected with
sacrifices on b5 one possible way to go
is this and now white can even take on
b5 yeah
this turns out to be a excellent why
does threatening 95m and what happens if
black takes well after this of course
the Queen Hanks and where should it go
cannot go to 85 or be six or the eight
you have to go here and after Queen a5
the combined threat of 97 and via the
simple capture of the Queen just wins
that means that black cannot take only 5
but 95 is really a strong threat and
like him really needs to react to that
what what should he play I mean let's
say hmm what else could Black Flame
there should be 6
for example covering d5 yeah then white
can even just play here and threaten
this again yeah it's a very
uncomfortable position for blanket it's
really problematic like it cannot really
grab the pawn or just it is connected to
uterus but you cannot allow to take and
this is why you play d5 at the end
however this move is very close to being
a strategical gap capitulation because
now white is just excellent
look at this annoyed cannot go here
cannot go to h6 black has big
development issues and white has earn
has already made plan we just played h4
intending of course just h5 breaking out
the h-file and black simply has too many
bad pieces the bishop on g7 the Queen
and this pawn configuration is also not
especially great because it leaves
gaping holes on c5 and 85 and this does
not help in opening up the queenside
after age four he played Queen a5 and
now just aged five very logical Knight
b6 in getting a night near the king
before I was also possible but just have
a look at this Knight be one Queen takes
yeah and now White has more than one
interesting continuation one interesting
line is e six takes 95 which leads to a
very strong game for right
okay he's given up after a two pawn but
Black has absolutely no threat cm this
is one idea or you can just take him and
then go with these six not bad at all
even the very simple Queen takes before
this is good for white just going to to
a3 if everything else fails and what has
the better structure my farm it's not
the most powerful though with the e6 and
the city stronger so before does not
help
late night b6 as I mentioned and now he
took on g6 and it takes yeah F takes
it's not a move you you like to play but
after that for example white can also
just play the prophylactic move B 3
covering c4 and ask like yeah what is
your next what is your plan here this
Bishop is just writing on granite and
white can easily improve his position
further yeah for example let's get the
King over try to relocate the knight to
c5 many ideas to increase the pressure
also just moving the bishop
ruk h1 is quite powerful he recaptured
with the F pawn and here white has a
nice choice he played a3 a good
prophylactic move
there also was again the must be three
that the computer simply loves maybe it
is really the strongest it's possible it
keeps those squares under control and
strategically speaking blankets close to
busted anyway full of holes and and
weaknesses of the position a3 would be 8
and 94 this is nitrous idea and it's a
very good one yeah like yeah like to
hear he decided to avoid the Queen trade
this is the the most obvious move of
course but this leads to an excellent
endgame the night transfer from c3 my
422 was very useful because you get to
the crucial square on b3 yeah this is
just a torture for black I guess this is
why he played before you just wanted to
to make it make it come make it
complicated 195 very nice square but
what else can you hope for and black
played night c4 at least where this
white probably needs to capture antedate
at least with this secret to somewhat
dangerous looking pawns
near the king yeah the the answer here
for simple but very very good what is
blanked blacks next move the main issue
is that this night on c5 is just a
monster piece it covers a four it
detects all kinds of vital squares and
it cannot be taken but like
not even challenged it's a they only
possible with very very long maneuvers
that don't work at the end it's probably
lost already for black cannot save the
position the computer recommendation
funny enough is quit d8 just retreating
but this also has an active idea with
Queen d5 I think this is let's say
compared to lots of other defensive
trisys is fairly fairly stubborn and
white has some still has to find the the
best possible way to get his offensive
going it's not clear what is the what
the best move order is one point could
be to get the Queen over to the King
side for example something like this
Bishop g5 and Queen f4 to get the Queen
over blacks count of players mentioned
is very limited so you can use the Queen
for an attack yeah this didn't happen he
played c3 understandable decision of
course you want to open it up on the
Queen side but at the end it does not
threaten much the Queen moves check
takes and King takes white can also just
take it this is better than playing the
typical King b1 move just keeping the
pawn as a shield this is complicated
black for example can play and b3 and
try to muddy the bottom just take it
it's the easiest I mean the king is not
in danger on b3 just pawn takes and this
Bishop on g7 well until this is a factor
on the long diagonal some some amazing
things need to happen he 5 and d4 need
to go so this is just some plain good b3
+ c3 keeping it closed Queen d8 and
after that you can
treat this is a small technical exercise
if you like what is White's most forcing
way to win the game also take note that
if you have an idea check it twice what
legs possible replies are going to be
silent for a couple of seconds so that
you can actually treat this as an
exercise okay
well the correct move is rook takes edge
time not too difficult but what you need
to see beforehand is that well the route
capture is very simple you just check go
here and after king evade this even ig5
which leads to a checkmate instead of
the simple material win but this is my
business better mate is a mate is a mate
yeah like it's busted this is the check
line that takes the longest bet it's not
not very challenging for white easy to
find moves so this is the much more
stubborn defense that you need to see
beforehand and Queen see for me it's the
point of it you attack the knight year
so that group takes check green g8 is an
easy win guy played King of eight and
now Knight g5
yup blacks position is is falling apart
big threat
again a big threat here the only move to
continue but it does not help check the
96 move immediately also was winning
instead of trading Queens but if you see
one very subjective that wins you can
you can just go for that check check
yeah why this grabbing pawns and how is
this night ever going to get into the
game it's so hampered by the e5 pawn and
of course this is just just taken
oops no this one yeah he tried to rook
d7 and now white after Luke a1 just went
after this week pawn it took it yeah and
here like could have resigned to which
after Lucy 7 Kings 2 2 he did on this
later yeah a very clean win by an iTouch
who manages to finish the tournament
with two wins that still means yeah he's
happy he's had a real bad tournament
with lots of losses and some
questionable play but at least he won
two games at the end which somewhat yeah
it's a slight consolation for the bed
player earlier he still needs he still
loses many rating points and it could
have been even worse if you look at the
games played before that yeah quick few
words about his opponent here Richard
reported and garyun junior player still
I think is 17 or 18 years old yeah he's
made a really impressive debut and the
the bigger winner here of the the the a
tournament in
like and he mostly yeah impressed with a
very creative opening play playing all
kinds of unknown unusual new openings
however I think that while this is an
very survicam change to to conventional
play he sometimes ya did yeah did
overdid it a bit he played so creative
that you can just call it bad if you are
if you are more more direct in your new
assessment for instance this game
against NIDA just this is just an
unplayable opening like was basically
toast after nine or ten moves and this
is simply not acceptable on that level
so he probably needs to in the long run
mix it play some creative lines for
surprise well you play some more
conventional openings I think this is
probably the key to to to more success
in and does those big tournaments
however take into account that he never
ever played this kind of opposition
before so it's it wasn't a bad
performance he lost a couple of rating
points but it's not easy at all to play
against all those experienced top-class
players all right the next game Gelfand
against hari krishna yeah quickly
summing up them tournament for those two
players how krishna has been playing
very solidly winning some some nice
games and he suddenly I guess satisfied
with his performance while Gelfand is
having a real bad tournament he's near
the end of the table for most of the
time only scoring one win if I'm not
mistaken so let's see what happened
the final game there from the opening
with C voice switching between his first
moves usually between C for D for NIDA 3
and here we get to the to the Queen's
Gambit and surprisingly harikrishna
plays some Knight f6 allowing them the
classical exchange which nowadays is
quite rarely played on top level it's
some considered to give white somewhat
somewhat easy game not like why does
winning or anything but it's usually
very comfortable for white who can
select one of many promising setups not
GE to what Kasparov has championed
Knight f3 at age 3 Karpov favorite line
and various yeah mixes of setups who can
also cancel long in some variations and
all of those lines had very good score
for white high Krishna whatever here is
some play an interesting variation he
plays a g6
you should age 4 and then Knight age 5
but I don't really understand this why
he played h6 it is well known that night
h5 is on line here the some line and
this has a very solid reputation
actually and is in my opinion one of the
best lines that black can play and the
exchange Queens gambit declined it's
almost the same in the game but with h6
played and I think h6 is simply two
White's benefit you can add various
stages in the game you can compare the
position with h6 on the board and
without h6 and almost all of the time
you see that it's more
double if you have the age porn at home
let's look at the game yeah now we see a
one idea of blacks plane he managed to
exchange the dark square bishop this
gave the Queen a good square only 7 and
black is also preparing to move out the
bishop and then castle long even you
don't necessarily need to cancel long in
the line without age 6
like sometimes cast castles short but
long castles is the the main point you
can put this on the board this is very
well known without the age 6 move and
now after King be one king be eight
rooks see one awesome well known using
the half-open see file intending Knight
a form black played tonight f6 back yeah
this is also a possible retreat in the
line with out age six
another ideas g6 97 and Bishop f5
the alternative blacks move however is
completely ok Knight f6 Knight a form
and black now plays Knight e4 this is at
least in my opinion slightly surprising
I guess I wouldn't have put the night
only for simply because I don't like to
get this pawn structure change but it's
probably not the end of the world but it
does not seem to equalize I would I
would prefer this I guess and now maybe
98 a 98 is an idea to play for 96
however 95 is a good reply which even
intends
take c6 now this is some a bit tricky
and rooks III eb-3 okay yeah maybe black
needs to play 94 after all it's not
disastrous move just that I am I don't
like it so much what I really like to do
is to exchange those bishops but this is
much more difficult with h6 being played
and because you'd like to play g6 and
the knight then goes to g7 or to f6 and
then a of Bishop f5 this is some
difficult to do now yeah well in the
game 94 as mentioned it's not a disaster
but I don't like this pawn structure
transformation so much one reason is
that the knight on e5 now again benefits
from this h6 move because let's just put
it on 187 just put it back then f6 is a
good reply and the night does not have
night g6 now f6 it's not a really good
idea losing the exchange black can play
this but White has simply plucking f1
and it's still a fork they took him and
played rock defy this has been the idea
getting the rook over to d5 yeah this
position is some of course not a
disaster for black but I think white
still has the slight nagging edge of
player on the Queen side
Brooke c3 creating a weakness and back
yeah this is all very logical but still
Black has problems this for example is
some slightly weak pawn that gets
attacked later yeah here black takes the
chance to to get rid of the bishop
but some it's not clear that you needed
to do that you could also maybe just sit
and wait with Bishop f7 possible he
decided to take it and return and and
I'm not sure if this was really so good
to exchange after rook c5 then it's this
nagging pressure the a five point is
week the e4 pawn is somewhat weak yeah
it's very uncomfortable to defend and
then the game will see that harikrishna
really quickly gets into trouble
it takes place um
Quincy seven yeah maybe here there's
room for an improvement yeah you can
consider rook t5 maybe maybe this is
what you should have done getting rid of
the rook or activating the rook yeah
this makes a good a good impression
actually if white now takes and place
queen b5 there is um probably just Queen
to d6 yeah if white takes oops
there's Queen edge to with some counter
play yeah that's not entirely clear but
rook t5 is maybe better than what he
played he played Queen c7 and now queen
g4 has strong putting pressure on
various spots yeah b6 very committal
move weakening the C pawn but I guess
black couldn't stand the sight of this
rook any longer always attacking a5 so I
played that and after who p8 white went
ahead with d5 it was so difficult to
protect the upon therefore rupee ed D 5
and after c5 White has won the pawn yeah
that's not the end of the world black
can get it back with rook th because now
the rook is somewhat yeah it's not a
very lucky position
this look combined with the weakness of
the deep on so black has got got it back
here white could have taken on b6 this
is very similar to what happens now he
traded and exactly here white could have
taken it is not so dangerous though
after King a 796 there is rook d2 and
black will have enough counter play I
guess he still needs to be cautious but
it should be enough something like this
okay here yeah here in something like
this I think black has enough activity
to compensate for the pawn he's got even
ideas to push the pawns here further
supported by the King and well it's of
course a matter of peace activity and
the rook on f2 was just just very strong
I think this should end in the John Doe
black must be cautious of course this is
why white avoided the caption king z2
was much stronger and I think here it's
one spot where you need to look for an
improvement because what I Krishna is
playing I think is losing and and really
losing mathematically I guess the only
movie is route g5 of you it's not such a
such a great lets you play with big joy
but probably you need to do it anyway
like g4 and then King here trying to get
counter play with the edge pawn or or
the F pawn black is passive but it's
probably not a matter of liking this
position and the alternative is just
lost
he played king c7 surprisingly and so
after the check of course he is
committed to rook d7 and
this is a root trade and I think that
this can you point and give after a four
is just lost maybe if someone has really
lots of time on their hands and maybe a
computer to assist and maybe someone can
find a safe for black I wasn't able to I
think that what Galvan played here is
normal and and good a for is of course
an important move not a difficult one
but important yeah this is fixing the
plants so that the two points here stop
three points very important check and
now after before we see that white is
pushing the points and he will get a
passer and that the ante should be able
to trade this passed pawn against the
two Queen seconds I think it is just
lost I mean maybe someone finds a
miracle defense but I don't see it
g v g3 and they're formed here we go
it's it's not difficult at all and here
more if I this coming he took played c4
and after he 45 black resigned there is
no way to avoid the scenario that I
described and white wins this pawn and
the game yeah it was simply a game where
like was always struggling to prove full
equality it was always a slight
disadvantage around here I think black
has made some progress and does not
substantially worse of course but I
think after the trade here here this is
starting to to get really annoying as
there is no counter play and white has
some points that he can attack if
efore g7 a5 and at the end with limited
time I guess harikrishna
crumbled under pressure so slight
consolation for Gelfand who's winning as
his final game still he certainly is
looking forward to start in a couple of
days in Zurich - yeah - start with a
fresh plate and maybe play more
successfully okay let's go to the next
game Nakamura against GUI and see for
Nakamura playing all opening moves we
get this line where black is trying to
open up the center in the symmetrical
English this can easily lead to a broom
fault type of position for example after
d4 black takes g6 we can transpose -
Grune fat directly however and a camera
had a different idea
and this is not forced by the way after
d4 black can play many others the camera
has an entirely different idea plays
efore which is interesting to see for me
personally because this is a line that I
have played myself for a number of years
I didn't get it too often the d5c 595
line is not very popular and this is a
very very sharp setup one important
point is that blacks only reply of value
is not before this is also what was
played in the game this for example
after D takes Queen Chang's King takes
is surprisingly problematic for black as
the c-4 move is a big issue white will
attack it with Bishop III and then a 4
92 94 this is a very comfortable game
for white with already a tango
advantage yeah well it's very very well
known to good players at Knight c3 it's
not good
you played night before and this looks
at this weekend square of course the
following line is really a really funny
Bishop c4 it's played by nakamura check
93 and now King e2 which looks really
really funny but okay White has an
excellent development but black is
moving the night all the time so this is
a valid way to play play tonight I have
four check of course not taking on c1
for example speeding upwards development
ok the check King f1 and 96 this was
really necessary to prevent a good
deform yeah in this position white has
tried many moves my move here always was
before which also is very interesting it
offers a pawn if black takes 92 white
will have a huge center in compensation
for the pawn and one important feature
is that the knight of course only sixes
far from ideally placed after before I
have a black has other moves he does not
necessarily need to to capture it he can
for instance play the move on g6
and after the capture Bishop g7 to play
on on the weaknesses cm okay but
Nakamura is going for 95 which is an
alternative and here black must be
cautious
there's more than one playable move here
one move however that is not playable
but it's played from time to time even
by strong players it's 97 and this is
leading to a quick disaster after Knight
f-cell
it's quite quite nice King takes vicious
takes King takes and cd3 check the poor
King King d6 and then just D for opening
up the position and blacks position will
fall apart this is not playable and all
everything's on there tech iam which
means that 97 is real lemon so what
should black play
he played knight c6 a good decision and
without any prejudices plate white now
takes and phone takes this is what I
meant without prejudice because yeah
well this looks looks terrible but it is
not so terrible at all those pawns
control important squares of course d4
but also d5 and b5 and black can
continue with the fianchetto to get the
bishop out a very interesting uneven
position you know all this means that
it's a very double-edged position
what has this week square in the center
that can be used by black black's pawn
structure is bad
white hasn't castled he's got a nice
bishop the ones he form and black has a
slightly weird piece only six that
certainly needs to move at some point to
get the bishops out yeah it's very
unclear and Nakamura's playing a very
direct moves no he just attacks the weak
c5 pawn which I find slightly surprising
I would have expected a move like this
Rio or something like that but this is
just far more straightforward
it just says okay what about the poem
how do you protect it and in fact if
black plays a move like g6 um white has
some some other ideas besides the the
I can even consider h4 it's not so clear
to find a mushroom like he decided to
play 94 and even sacrifice the weak c5
pawn which I took so what a strange
position g6 black is playing for
compensation Bishop e6 trades and Bishop
to g7 yeah like has some compensation
for the poem this is I think clear but
is it enough hmm have to say I am I'm
not really not really sure and c6 is
hanging here check my camera takes it
it's worth the check
so an understandable decision like goes
to f8 and white plays Queen a6 cover the
sensitive square so that 23 is not not
coming quickly yeah White's position is
on the other hand really disorganized
he's got the King here the rook is bad
as a consequence Knight is not well
placed on b3 and well okay the bishop on
c1 is just just bad and you cannot
easily and quickly complete development
oops
yeah I should have switched off the Jets
yeah you cannot easily complete
development while two pawns is quite a
lot yeah okay
94 plate and the trade and d3 there in
logical white is certainly willing to
return one pawn for for completing
development King g7 and h4 it tries to
use the rook on its initial Square not
the only idea let's say g3 would be a
more conservative way to play but the
question is is this too slow black can
even
Sidda move like Quincy ate this this
side twice with the idea Queen age three
and pretty much forces the Queen trade
rook takes not sure which one both make
some sense but the point is this anyway
black gets to c2 and this is certainly
enough to to have enough compensation
and be able to at least draw it
therefore I guess each form trying to
use the rook directly and black just
blocked it with h5 Ruka three important
point and Queen d7 yeah try to get
something on the C file it could be one
getting out of the diagonal no black
played rook c8 and all this is not so
easy to assess black has definite
compensation but I'm not 100% sure if it
is enough in the game it it comes a
parent rather quickly that white has no
big chance to do to get to get to
something substantial but I'm not 100%
sure about that if this is best play and
let's have a look what happened
he played Bishop III getting rid of the
d4 Bishop certainly is a good idea and
Roxy - of course this was the idea all
along Queen a5 yeah possibly switching
the Queen over but also covering
sensitive squares would be 8 + b3 yeah
now black went back to or went to c8 now
trying to use the second-ranked even
more
Kim Ji Won and rookie - of course
attending Brooke II - see - and this
already would be a quite unpleasant for
white check it took it
Queen takes and Raquel three yeah and
like of course just forward
attacking here not only one attacking
here and attacking on f2 and what this
means that black already gets something
back
yeah white girls for counter play
against f7 that black can easily cover
yeah I think he had some almost I'm
almost sure that black should be able to
draw him this is a weak pawn and he's so
active on the second ring check yeah
sure we see that we have a technical
tactical operation after that the Queen
needs to give up the attack on f7
obviously in this tactical sequence
check that happened but now black
already has secured the draw because the
White King is so weak now Queen h4 Queen
e1 is resonating perpetual after Queen
d7 check check exactly that happened
yeah in this game the giri defended very
actively sacrificing two pawns maybe
there was something for nakum right at
one point to somehow preserve a little
edge
but I didn't really see it the computer
if you're looking into the computer it
always gives white a little something I
mean far less than two pawns of course
just 0.4 0.3 and even if you give it
give it a few moves it's no clear
assessment only that black has definite
compensation but it's very hard to judge
if it is enough in a practical game I
think blacks plays completely okay it's
not at all easy to to play for for white
okay let's get to the next game Coyoacan
against Dominguez
to get my notes here okay
let's see what happened yeah nice
transposition to the Sicilian of course
Dominguez is a regular Sicilian player
so this is not one of those cases where
Nydia three was was played and then
someone plays d5 forgetting about the
Sicilian and of course kayaking is a
it's a long time 1.e4 player so we only
have was slightly funky move order to
position that both players know well
okay I catch a bit surprised and he
plays Bishop b5 check here he normally
plays the open but of course the Bishop
b5 lines have gained lots of popularity
in recent years against 296 I mean here
you can even argue that this is by now
the mainline people prefer that really
to deform as no one really gets anywhere
against especially curve okay check this
is somewhat different affair check but
it's also leading to two interesting
play this Queenie to Luke the one
approach has been popular recently what
white is trying to do is to get a good
version of other lines with C 3 and d 4
or in some cases with c4 in default
leading to Amarok C point type of
position black plays rook c8 C 3 and E 6
so it seems that he's ready for him for
the French type confirmation which would
rise after D form takes takes d5 e5 and
now probably 94 you sometimes need to be
cautious with 94 in this kind of
position because if white moves the
knight then f3m threatens the winner
piece for example 9
you won if black now plays a silly move
let's say yeah it doesn't make much
sense what I'm but I'm saying here yeah
well the problem is after night you won
I'm just getting to the point directly
black can take here
it's a funny tactic because of this
hangings he won bishop black of course
wins in a very straightforward manner
here what I was getting at is that f3
just ignore this tactic if black ignores
oops not this that's f3 and this night
does not have any square it oops it
cannot go here here here whatever
everything's covered in this concrete
position it's still not working utility
fall but I was just trying to say that
getting in the center can be tricky so
here is no problem and after 92 this
kind of position is very well known and
also very equal black has no problems at
all but it's very difficult to do
something as black here white can simply
double on the C file and what does blood
going to do in the long run very
difficult for for active play however
kayaking is playing something completely
different
he took with a knight which I find
really strange because well if you want
to go forma Roxy bind and this is
happening super good see form why not do
that before I mean why why c3 than in
the first place why not try to save save
this tempo
maybe d4 here let's say just for example
something like this and then c4 looks
like
gain of a temple yeah well this is
strange but it's probably not not not a
mistake or anything Bishop here and now
we went back to f3 probably wanting to
avoid further trades Quincy 795 wasn't
thread also see for the more oxy point a
six and now I played to move B three
okay oh I know it may sound a bit
strange but in this position there is a
technical tactical opportunity for black
if you want you can try to find it for
yourself I'll be quite a couple of
seconds yeah I'm going to show it black
has a very funny tactical move he can
take on e4 and he did in the game
b3 has weakened the long diagonal and if
white recaptures thus Bishop f6 yeah and
this is just quite an embarrassing
situation white can play 94 but this is
not really great amongst others there's
a move D 5 p.m. yeah the idea being that
CD 94 is flat-out winning as Luke takes
check leads to a checkmate even yeah
this was really a funny move 34 you can
work out some some lines for yourself if
you like
after this he played 93 and avoided the
line that I was just shot the thing is
that white has some compensation it is
of course not a planned sacrifice but
White has to some compensation because
of the nice Queen early form of a
centralized and this rook is already
putting some pressure on the D pawn we
see that in some moves that white is
trying really formed for concrete
concrete counter play d4 d5 and so on
black and still enjoys this
japón but it's not a technical position
yet it's the middlegame type of position
where many things are possible and many
mistakes are possible let's continue a
few moves queen g3 yeah look d6 was not
possible due to 95 a very nice technical
trick that is worth remembering the rook
is now attacked and isolated and the
queen is saying so black is winning the
exchange yeah now it is threatened
because the Queen is protected so black
needed to do something against it and
now Knight inch phone yeah
blacks idea was amongst others 96 to f4
so why does stopping that I don't know
why this is popping up
why does stopping that so I can take the
Nydia b5 and white white took because c4
was saying yet after this trade and 27
we have a position where black is
enjoying this is extra pawn and he also
has a decent pawn structure and a good
King position there's it's clear that
black is very close to to get in a
position that that he should win but we
see that
coyoacán is putting up with very
stubborn defense he attacks the
weaknesses that black also has and it
turns out that yeah he trades they trade
those two bonds it turns out that at the
end white has won this pawn but black
has a very solid structure
and can play against the king black is
still somewhat better but it's not a
substantial problem I guess maybe you
need to to look for some improvements
around here black really should keep
something but he didn't manage in the
game
I didn't analyze this part of the game
so so thoroughly here maybe some
opportunity what sir
what's king as it's very weak
yeah but how do you get get an attack in
this position it's um it's the rook
suddenly needs to play rook e8 makes
lots of sense like this would be three
yeah good move combining attack and
defense
genic and drop g3 yeah it still looks a
bit a bit more comfortable form for
black but how do you win actually not
easy at all
check check check a couple of check
check and then activated the rook yeah
but this now allows some counter play
with the pawns we all move 40 I guess
both players had some sometime issues
and it turns out that before could have
been a fatal mistake
it seems that white should probably play
move like Wiener 3 trying to trade
Queens
for example this straight now is not
convincing at all well before what was
played in the game but yeah it's move 40
probably played under serious time
pressure leads to trouble
after a form played b5 a counter-attack
against the rock rock c2
would be three and drew each this looks
very convincing right there is strong
check threat King f12 to cover that and
now he played rook takes a two here he
also had the possibility to play f3 and
this seems to be quite strong
keeping the rook on e 2 and threatening
various attacks like this it's difficult
to find even a playable a playable reply
rookie 3 years the computer suggestion
but after the trade it's a Quincy
forecheck followed by a forum like
should be should be winning really this
is hanging and the King is so weak this
is probably decisive f3 was I guess
better than what was played in the game
the capture f3 glad to get some loot for
the king I guess Queen back threatening
on g2 and queen d3 so a queen trade I
think why it was probably glad that he
managed that black also could have gone
for Queen a8 trying to keep the Queens
on the board this is an alternative and
it's not looking very natural I must
admit but she had say after the check
King rooks III yeah black can just take
H 2 and what is y doing him he can he
has a hard time to defend against rook
takes h2 what he does not have any
substantial count to play against the
king maybe black didn't mind the Queen
trade so much but it turns out that this
is at least a position that white can
fight on check takes and here yeah
the rook is active and it's attacking
the important d5
this is quite fast I guess b2k I'm not
sure but rupee three this is really good
it looks quite logical to stay on the
second rank but okay the F pawn has a
weakness as well so it takes it and now
moves to the pawns this endgame looks of
course very critical for white black is
a pawn up and he is pushing the the King
side pawns the question is how many what
what kind of defensive resources are
there
he played King D to just the most active
move activating the King and black has a
hard time not to take it if you if you
don't take at the moment just for
argument's sake let's say you play King
moves on then King c2 is coming and
where's the rook going now if you take
now the B point is very very quick and
probably quick enough to secure at least
at all
therefore it's it's tricky you need to
take it on a3 anyway and this is what
you did
King C 2 and here this this again leads
to a direct draw check you play the
check their phone and now tries to get
behind the phone and it really feels
that that black should win here but how
do you actually do that in the game we
see that Jack this is not so trivial
they repeat it a couple of times and now
black is going the long road going in
front of the poor
yeah and now we have a position where
basically king and rook on the fifth
fighting against the three pawns well
the black rook cannot move and yeah if
you ask me this is maybe a draw I don't
really see how black gets ahead here
white was approaching with the king and
it's not it's not apparent how those
spots even move
maybe black should have tried to to go
this way like this for example but does
this really win it's not clear to me
let's say h5 movie 3 page 4
King G - and what now how does black
make any progress King f5 feathers check
King h5 I just go to b5 it's probably a
draw and I'm not really sure where
Domingues spoiled it
he it feels like he should have won but
how do you actually win it and I'm not
sure at all I mean around here it's
maybe the way to other the point to look
for improvements
it really looks very fishy for white
with the King cut off on the second rank
so it's hard to imagine it that black
should not win but it didn't materialize
in the game it also shows that that rook
end games have those really notorious
with rhetoric notorious sorry
notorious drawing tendency those
openings or those end games tend to be
far more Jewish than let's say
especially King and pawn endings they
are very often just won or lost and it
depends on one tempo Howard Howard ends
well in Luke end games very often the
drawing modulus is pretty wide so at the
end draw for those two players they both
were in some some turn for sometime when
potential for first place but didn't
really didn't really get near Anyang and
while we're talking about I have
completely forgot to make a quick
summary of Nakamura and give his
tournament sorry I forgot about that you
are Nakamura certainly I think he also
tweeted something like okay I'm glad
that this is over it really wasn't a
good tournament let's start with a fresh
mind in Zurich yeah he certainly was not
satisfied had a couple of unfortunate
games and did really manage to win a lot
well forgive reott certainly was an
excellent tournament he's the only
mister player with two two wins no
losses which is really great and he's on
second place we already know that
Aronian won the tournament this is no
secret he already had secured it after
the penultimate round and what Giri is
so on second place very nice results it
it was a big distance to Aronian but
he's still very very young only turning
let's think about that is it turning 20
this year I think I think it's 19 so
very young and promising player okay um
next game let's go to rusty so against
Kara wanna and this is a game that
follows theory for a very long time as
it turns out and I don't know the theory
I just looked it up in my database and
for for around 20 moves we follow
unknown
example so it's playing the very
theoretical look be one line after which
black has more than one interesting
option there are also options would like
to to just go for this sort of cards and
approach get a playable game and let's
say try to play complicated middle game
and game and so on and this is one one
approach that black can take here but
you can also play the most theoretical
way and this is capturing and giving
this check on a5 which grabs the a pawn
white can play Queen d2 but this is
leading to check an endgame that is
believed to be OK for black for a long
time yeah this is a porn grab but white
has some compensation for it the Queen
does not have so many squares it can be
a liability white has the center of
course the rook is making it difficult
for black to easily develop the c8
bishop and then general white is better
developed here black has many possible
defenses Bishop g4 is probably the main
line and it turns out that all this has
been played white now grabs the pawn on
b7 black has returned this and the idea
is to quickly check this moves we see
the idea quickly get the a pawn rolling
yeah this is the counter play and
basically it's the only idea that black
has and in this position which is not
meant in a negative way one idea is
perfectly enough it if it is good
yeah blacks counter plays based on the a
pawn and it seems that this always gives
him enough play White's right Queen a1
getting rid of the Queens and tried to
put some pressure on this a
maybe combining it with d5 at the right
moment note that this is really a
question of the right moment submission
on g7 SS very strong plate
Luke a8 bishop a 4 and a 6 in fact we
only know one move ago have seen a new
move this all had been played before and
I don't think that black has much reason
to complain he always has the same
pramanas mentioned 92 and now black goes
for a change of structure I guess or
let's say wrong wrong word the structure
also changes but mostly it is the the
material distribution that gets gets
shaken um
I think black was right in playing what
what he played if you don't grab one
default what he did then white maybe
really manages to improve like 93 f3
play those small improving moves and
maybe get the apron so 94 I think is the
the correct decision after that white of
course takes on d7 this was hanging and
now check we got 92 king of one Bishop
takes and King takes and now we see we
have a situation where White has two
minor pieces against rook and pawn
fortunately for black this is the apron
supported by the bishop and this I think
means that it is enough compensation for
black white is some our conversation is
the wrong word but the distribution of
material is okay for black I guess in
the game relatively quickly they agreed
to a draw
ever repetition here after that the game
was agreed drawn I have tried to work
out yeah to work out the concrete line
that really is a draw and I didn't
manage really I mean it's I think they
really it could have continued a bit
more but it is certainly an okay
position what I think is a line that can
be played as bishops III just to show
how it could have continued this
threatening to take and play whoopsy a
it's just for him for example this is
coops come on this is what I'm talking
about winning one of the bishops so
white better does something against the
threat maybe move the knight yeah let's
say Knight here and then you can try to
activate or you can try to go here and
harass the bishops the combination of
the rook and the ape on should always be
enough but it's hard to yeah think of a
concrete drawing line
what can also retreat and and camera
that but then III and rugby to you know
can get a bit dangerous on something
like that
there still would be - I mean bit of a
shame I would like to see this game
continued but it's probably a fair
result and would have ended the draw
even if they had played more moves it's
quite likely yeah I think both Wesley so
and Kawana yeah I mean so is one of
those guys who really had high rating
for quite quite a while but he does not
have much experience in
those big tournaments so I think he's
probably satisfied with this result or
koala being close to the number three
spot certainly expected more but we had
some unfortunate games for instance the
loss yesterday against knowledge was
certainly quite quite frustrating when
he blundered in in time pressure okay so
let's go to the final game that I'm
going to analyze from this tournament of
courses Aronian against Vanveen II
Aronian already is the winner of this
tournament he played fantastic and
fantastic first ten games winning
winning six I think winning six games
four draws and really playing excellent
chess when really hadn't an up-and-down
tournament playing some nice wins losing
games he's a fighter and did a good job
I think let's see what what happens here
yeah Aronian going for deform and slide
surprised the Dutch defense yeah okay
the Dutch played by a Dutchman shouldn't
be a surprise but when Vania is only
playing this opening quite rarely he
sometimes plays it but it's not a main
feature of his repertoire and maybe this
was specifically yet against sironia and
because to be honest the latest games
that are only on played against the
Dutch especially the Dutch Leningrad
variation have been quite weird he
played some some weird stuff against
that with Bishop f4 and this is quite
quite difficult to to understand why is
he's playing like that because there are
some I mean the Dutch is not and not a
bad opening not really it's a bit risky
but not bad and white as many good
positional lines against it and it's
quite strange that Aronian is playing
something like that again is going for a
bishop
for setup in them in the san luis
tournament last year against Carlton he
had to plate also Bishop f4 back then in
connection with c4 Knight c3 and d3 and
Carlsen hadn't had a really nice
position in this in this game really
strange opening choice and again he's
playing something like that
but he has changed his approach of it we
see that he's starting with Bishop f4 d3
and maybe keeps this option open
and now convenience playing a really
cool move I think he's playing age 60 he
is not content with g6 the the leningrad
type setup but he wants to play d5
straightaway and well this is what he's
doing h3 g5 okay Bishop h2 and Bishop g7
so a very enterprising start for black
of course this kind of setup with g5 can
easily backfire
I mean whereas you can go to going to be
probably not on the Queen side but on g8
on age 7 and it's a long-term problem of
the Dutch defense that you have very
often moved your pawns in front of the
king this is all nice as long as you
have pieces protecting a king but in the
long run it can get tricky okay he's
continuing in this very slow manner with
C 392 and just develops pieces rook b8
somewhat strange it's like really
planning b5 maybe but it's not going for
it
Queen e8 preparing e5 yeah what what is
a bit strange about why it's a setup is
that it does not aspire at all to to get
an edge in the center white is just
putting his pieces on
decent squares but he's not fighting for
anything here black is the one to to be
active here Ruki one plate and queen age
five yeah here five was of course the
the typical way to play and I'm not so
sure what White's reply against that is
maybe he just would have taken and
played Bishop b5 hero Bishop c4 one
point is that quite often Black is
overextending in this type of position
it sometimes can arise from the Kings
Indian set up against the London as well
where you push your pawns like let's say
e v e4 and at the end well okay not
winning a piece at the end this Bishop
is getting really strong so black must
be careful with this timing and not
saying that II five is bad just know
it's it's still a double that reduces
decision to play that I think what he
played this is interesting as well he
played queen h5 getting near the king
and maybe hoping one day on a very good
day if this bishop is able to sacrifice
itself on a stream Queen c2 just
attacking the pawn is answered by g4
yeah no choice it takes Knight takes and
now Bishop b5 try to increase the
pressure if black plays d5 it's just an
an indirect move that applies pressure
to the center King h8 this is a sensible
move getting out of all kinds of checks
on c4 and b3 and now Queen b3 it's not
so here to me what white is actually
doing if you ask me if what he's doing
is he is trying to set up a very solid
position and tries to provoke then veiny
and doing something active I mean it's
quite clear that blacks position is
yeah it looks like black might get some
kind of a tech going with the night on
g4 the Queen on h5 black might get over
optimistic and I think Aronian wanted to
somehow lure him to to to attack and
this actually happened 98 okay this is a
lot of passive move with selective move
he wants to go to e6 and we see that
after this black has activated tonight
and the snide might join the action on
the kingside however this v5 business
has also weakened blacks position he has
lots of porn weaknesses c5 is a
potentially weak pawn and square
weaknesses lots of weaknesses all along
here here here this is all week and it's
not so clear how black is going to
continuous attack we see that after the
centralizing move rook 81 he played c5
Queen b3 and now went for a regrouping
Bishop first here and then back why a d7
to c6 and this is of course a good
diagonal for the bishop this should be -
this is probably intending Knight age 2
which would I think helped quite a bit
of human exchange this and Frieda be for
square for night when I'm talking about
this did this idea let's just put
something slow on the board let's say b6
not a great move yeah this isn't
especially not great because 95 is also
a threat yeah this is in fact the main
threat not Knight h2 but Knight takes e5
this is why black pushed forward takes
and Bishop to h4
yeah now the pawn structure has changed
after
and for push and I think the funny thing
is that Aronian is getting exactly what
he wanted I believe Black was tempted to
push his pawns and at the end to look at
this there are weaknesses the spawn for
example this Square and after Bishop e7
Lee played rook f7 Bishop here and 95
exactly here is one critical position of
this game I think as I mentioned it went
really nicely for Aronian I didn't
really see much point in the setup
besides it's counter attacking potential
and this counter attacking potential
really worked to perfection as now his
pieces are are nicely placed rooks are
centralized or pieces are active and now
these seven bishop the same and i think
now in this position he should have
simply had gone for the c5 born it's
it's very easy to say it because it's
still very tricky but I think you should
just take it and I don't see much much
compensation one point is that sometimes
submission defines a good move
exchanging the the bishop on g7 yeah to
be honest I don't don't really see what
black is doing now it's still
complicated no doubt about it
but I don't really see black smooth
there also is 94 as a potential idea 94
and 96
for example after rook t8 covering this
this night there is 94 yeah I'm not I'm
not really sure why he didn't take the
computer is liking white a lot however
while I'm not sure if the clock times
are correct yet I read on the official
site that they were in a time scramble
so maybe he saw some ghost there I just
wanted to play in a more
conservative fashion and brought the the
bishop back
this of course keeps the structure
intact and we the the pawn structure
which is one feature here is unchanged
by that so it's not spoiling much but it
probably was a good opportunity to take
the pawn now look at five rows plate
Bishop d3 it went back and now we should
be one going for this idea yeah it would
be nice made on h7 oh it's a good idea
look B 2 y 8 and here's another
situation where I think he maybe could
have gone for for porn hunting but this
kind of line some are not easy to play
especially if you really need to do it
with the bots and you don't have any any
computer assistants like the the analyst
has at home Quincy form is interesting
it has more than one good idea
one ideas of black plays 95 here you can
take cupcakes and Queen b3 this is a
very nice regrouping threatening made
and after that you have the nice move
Queen edge 3d and this is I think very
appealing for white the Queen is helping
in defense and canvas the bishop and you
have the idea to play Knight f3 and then
maybe try to do something on the e-file
I like this position a lot for white so
in general I think you know in a
theoretical sense in analytical sense
white is in good shape but it is not
easy to play at all he exchanged and
went for this which also looks perfectly
perfectly alright but in fact it has a
tactical drawback and now when William
had a good opportunity
he played the very nice-looking loofah
but a mistake
93 but he could have done this he could
have played 95 and this would have been
strong the ideas of course that this
Bishop is a liability and after 92 which
is probably necessary you can take check
I'm playing Knight f6 yeah and this is
the threatening Bishop f3 and this would
strip this Bishop of its defense here
white really doesn't have much
alternative to taking on f6 now
something like that and here only black
can be better a funny line here is Queen
c2 actually threatening mate after which
Bishop before can be played and here
what may be sure to sec the queen but we
get to get too far him it's clear that
only black can be better here 95 was a
good chance but he played that d3 which
is a very understandable move if you see
this kind of spectacular blow with a
little time you play it yeah you see
okay well this is put him on putting him
under pressure let's play this move and
yeah so so it it takes it takes only
phone all this is exchanged but now we
see that b7 is hanging and yeah
this is tricky the rook is also attacked
what should black do now after rook
takes III the most natural move I guess
White has amongst others this check
check back and Queen takes and yeah well
this is an extra pawn and no direct
attack so white can be very
this fight him however he played queen
g6 which is probably the better
practical choice group the age check
check King moves and exactly here is the
critical point but it's move 37 and
though I don't know the exact clock time
but Aronian was wasn't at one time he
could have played a very strong move and
this is roti six a deflection
the queen is protecting the rook and
yeah Black has has a big problem here if
you take it
check weenie fights also even going to
pick up the F pawn here so the best
defense is actually to to retreat it and
after the trade and the capture here
white is just playing with with with
extra material this is just a check
really
it's not easy technically I'm not saying
that but only white can win and this
pattern
he played Queen d5 and this is not
really enough black has a good reply now
played rookie six and in this position
black is threatening something or black
is intending to to take on history of
course and also has this oops this idea
to check on v1 yeah Aronian here played
he takes a fourth and now we know that
when really was also in time trouble and
if you want to treat this as an exercise
after the pawn capture on f4 give
yourself at best thirty seconds and try
to find the best move for black I leave
quite for a moment okay I'm going to
show the solution now did you find it
black has a really really cute move now
you played Bishop d4 check a very very
nice check and this is just very very
visual move somehow becoming cars of the
job if white takes and okay watch what
else should you do if white takes their
screen b1 you should do one and now like
can even check checkmate play like that
and checkmate white with the lone Knight
and the lone Brooke very nice very nice
checkmate yeah and the the awful thing
is after Bishop before there is no
alternative whatsoever if the King moves
there's always screen b1 or queen d3 in
this case checkmate
it's just completely over he takes a
form really bland of the game away
because sorry
that ya Aronian resigned of course it's
it's unavoidable now so he suffered a
loss after playing ten rounds of
excellent chassis really lost in the
last round against the really
unpredictable Dutchman Luke from vanie
it was a very very complicated fighting
game and a game where white certainly
had some chances to to win or at least
get a substantial advantage if we look
at this position where he blundered with
eat eggs at four it however turns out
that this is not easy at all for white
he has this red to answer and it seems
the computer is is giving 91 as the best
move and I can assure you that this is
not the type of move that you easily
play with little time on the clock it
just looks like a strange decision but
it covers g2 and after 93 it allows
Queen f3 and this seems to be in fact
still okay for white it's an equal
material and black does not have any
decisive attack at the moment so this
was the move that he needed to play but
this is very difficult to do with little
time so on the tournament after being an
absolutely fantastic Verona and ends on
a bit of a bit of a ya said note that he
actually lost the game at the end but he
certainly an overall can be very
satisfied with this play here in the
Netherlands great win for Aronian and I
think van Veen II also can be quite
satisfied with this tournament he played
very interesting fighting games and won
a couple of remarkable ones so um
a very very interesting tournament
overall I think it's a bit of a shame
that they cut it to 11 rounds and had
this many rest days I think this
maybe something to improve on just play
with a normal number of rest days and
not not so many alright I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this tournament
and as you already have guessed from
from my comments here
the Zurich tournament the Zurich chess
challenge also featuring the world
champion Magnus Carlsen is just around
the corner starting in a few days and I
guess I'll also do daily coverage maybe
even doing a livestream if possible I
need to check the exact starting times
and and and round and round dates but
I'm pretty sure I can manage something
like that if I do it I'll pass on this
information of course beforehand so that
you can tune in a few if you like I do
at least these kind of daily videos this
is this is some this is clear already
alright thanks for watching and yeah
let's see what time the top players do
in Zurich just in a couple of days